this video was made possible by better
help.com / Pakman where you can get
affordable online access to a licensed
therapist through text phone and video
chat
just click the link under this video so
Donald Trump gave his first press
conference in a while yesterday and it
very very quickly devolved into a sort
of deranged house of horrors and I'm
going to highlight it for you I couldn't
look away I had it on initially just
kind of in the background thinking I
would sort of listen but it very quickly
became the type of thing I really had to
focus my entire attention on and of
course the context of this press
conference is it comes the day after
Trump was laughed at by the entirety of
the United Nations special
General Assembly we discussed that a
couple of times now Donald Trump decided
to hold this press conference the day
before these hearings in which his
Supreme Court pick Brett Kavanaugh would
be under oath after his accuser
Christine Blasi Ford would be under oath
and we will get to that a little bit
later in the show and this press
conference has completely reinvigorated
the questions about Donald Trump's
cognitive capacity the questions about
his awareness of basic facts have been
around for a while but the the questions
about the cognitive capacity are fully
back enforced so I'm gonna show you a
few things from this press conference
the first is maybe the most nuanced
during his United Nations speech Donald
Trump talked about China interfering in
American elections but he sort of
conspicuously given what's been going on
made no mention at all of Russia
interfering in American elections and a
journalist asked him a very reasonable
question which was how do you compare
what you accused China of doing to what
Russia has done and Trump panicked
clearly didn't want to answer that
question and managed to give a rambling
disjointed answer that didn't even
mention Russia at all it barely even
related to Chinese interference either
so stick with this we're going to go
through it notice that there is no
answer and then almost immediately when
this answer is done
Trump ends the
conference so let's take it from the top
there are two small follow-ups one is
how would you compare the level of
interference you see today from the
Chinese to what Russia did in 2016 well
I think it's different if you look at
the Des Moines Register they have ads
that are made to look like editorials
saying about all you got to stop Trump
you got to stop him you got a vote
against him my farmers are Sankar these
are patriots you know on a network that
doesn't like me very much which is most
of them but a network that didn't
doesn't really treat me very good they
interviewed farmers and they got hurt
because you know all of a sudden China
steps by by the way they've started
buying again I don't know if you have
noticed and soybeans are going up and
things are going up and we've had very
little hurt from what I've done
in fact the markets have gone up and the
farmers are gonna do great but
ultimately but they had farmers and
these guys amazing I love them and they
voted for me and they loved me and they
said we don't care if we get hurt he's
doing the right thing and you know a lot
of people it's a complex game a lot of
people don't know exactly what it is
they don't know how to define tariffs
they don't know it is very different
than a tax although it's getting close
yeah so bear in mind he talks about
soybeans he talks about farmers he talks
about networks that don't quote treat
him good he talks about the stock market
and everybody's gonna do great no answer
to the question how do you compare the
scope of what you claim China did to
what Russia did and it continues we've
skipped over nothing here okay we're not
jumping ahead at all we're picking it up
from where we just left off this is
still presumably part of his answer
about Russian and Chinese interference
in the election remember the question
was compare the degree of Chinese
election interference to Russian
election interference but they know that
for the first time in many many years
they have a president that's fighting
for them that's not letting their jobs
be taken to other countries that's not
allowing
the kind of abuse that we I mean when
you look at what happened as an example
with NAFTA and four years because it was
never changed NAFTA was a defective deal
today it was signed you know why because
they had a VAT tax of seventeen percent
and nobody from this country knew that
and by the time they found out which was
about a week later nobody went and
changed it so you went many years and
they never changed it there was a vet
tax that Mexico God so we were 17 or 16
points behind before we even started
NAFTA was a horrible thing remember the
question
Russian election interference he's
talking about NAFTA and trade deals VAT
taxes Mexico and then continuing here
were not cutting anything out this is
still the same answer Trump continues so
the farmers and by the way the steel
workers you know I stopped the dumping
the dumping was horrible and now if they
want a dump that's okay but they've got
to pay the United States of America 25
percent on everything they dumped that's
ok yeah but as I told you before steel
is doing phenomenally well but the
farmers say this man's fighting for us
no president has ever fought for us
before and you really have to study
what's happened over the 15 years with a
farm the farmers have been decimated
over a 15 year period
they've been decimated the farmers are
gonna come out great these are great
people they're great great Patriots I
think we should finish with that one is
that okay yes and the Congress go ahead
let's go fast
stunning not even a pretend answer the
question was compare the degree of
Chinese election interference to Russian
election interference he talked about
almost everything but that like he
didn't get you know word about that I
would have loved it if the reporter who
followed up asked the exact same
question that's the strategy I would
like to see the media employee but I'm
sure it didn't happen not here they had
their own questions to move on to other
crazy moments Trump claiming that China
respects his very large brain when China
he was on a good show I won't mention
the name of the show recently and he was
saying that China has total respect for
Donald Trump
for Donald Trump's very very large brain
he said Donald Trump they don't know
what to do never happen is it's not a
large brain it's a large brain and then
here is Trump saying that when there are
sexual assault allegations he tends to
side with the accused not the accuser
this is kind of an interesting take and
notice that in this clip you have to pay
attention to this okay I'm gonna play
for you a minute and a half clip in this
minute and a half within actually about
55 seconds he claims never to have met
the women that accused him of sexual
assault and to have known them 15 to 20
years ago okay same clip same 60 seconds
he says women who have never met accused
me and women who I knew they were
actually women who I knew 15 to 20 years
ago how can both be true how are your
personal experiences being accused by
more than I've been accused I've been
accused make false accusation excuse me
I've been accused and I was accused by I
believe it was four women you can check
with Sean Hannity you can check with Fox
because they covered it very strongly
they know yeah who got paid excuse me
excuse me I was accused by four or five
women who got paid a lot of money to
make up stories about me we caught them
and the mainstream media refused to put
it on television they refused even write
about it there were four women and maybe
more I think the numbers four or five
sixteen but one had a mortgage paid off
her house $52,000 another one had other
things happen and the one that reported
it I believe was offered seven hundred
and fifty thousand dollars to say bad
things about me and she's the one that
reported it this woman is incredible she
reported it instead of taking the money
so I've had numerous accusations about
me
we know they I mean they made false
statements about me knowing they were
false I never met him I never met these
people never and what did they do what
did they do they took money in order to
say bad things I've had stories written
in
New York Times front page about four
women the whole top center front page of
the New York Times I think it was four
big pictures I said wow that's a big
thing what said these were women that
were quoted saying bad things about me
not the worst things about me but bad
things and I said gee that's too bad I
knew him a long time ago 15 years ago 20
years ago I said that's too bad I'm
surprised at them within 60 seconds he
says he never met the people and that he
knew them 15 to 20 years ago is anybody
listening this is a serial uncontained
liar and then cherry on top when
answering about Brett Kavanaugh sexual
assault and this is just where I don't
know how history will even explain this
he seems to say here that George
Washington the first president of the
United States had sexual assault
allegations against him which he seems
to know about but weren't widely
reported or something take a listen look
if we brought George Washington here and
we said we have George Washington the
Democrats would vote against him just so
you understand right and he may have had
a bad past who knows yeah he may have
had some I think accusations made didn't
he have a couple of things in his past
George Washington would be voted against
100% by Schumer and the con artists I
mean 100% under how to do historians
report about this in the future I mean
this goes beyond being valid for basic
political political analysis and it
becomes more of a sociological cultural
aberration the likes of which we've
never seen before and I hope we'll never
see again but that's actually my fear my
fear is that we will I'm scared that
this is what the United States is
becoming because remember that 40%
nearly 40% of the country supports this
they support this guy absolute house of
horrors press conference send me your
thoughts about it if you saw it I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show